speaking of eccentric people in la
there recently was an awards show for
hollywood
you didn't watch it i know no one did
either
no one else other than i think the
actors themselves this was the screen
actors
guild awards and
as ever they're just trying to alienate
as many people as they possibly can
the winner of one of these awards jason
sudeikis
wore a radical political
shirt during the zoom awards from his
living room
that i think carries with it shows you
not just what's wrong about
hollywood but what is wrong more broadly
in
our politics jason sudeikis
who is some sort of actor i don't really
know what he was on i kind of recognize
his face
he won the screen actors guild
award and he gave a very nice little
speech
and while he was giving his thank you
speech on zoom he wore a shirt that said
my body my choice take a listen and the
actor goes too
jason sedakis ted lasso
man oh man are you kidding me uh
wow thank you uh to to all my fellow
actors
i want to thank my mom for uh bringing
me to
plays and musicals in kansas city every
tourney company came through whether
it's fan of the opera or the cajon falls
uh
i want to thank my dad for taking me to
go see movies
uh took me to go see beverly hills cop
when i was nine years old
i knew at that point i wanted to be a
black cop from detroit
um getting there and again i thank my
fellow cast mates because they make me
uh better because i just again happy job
uh thank you again this is very
amazing appreciate it he's wearing a
shirt
defending abortion during his
acceptance speech and the first thing he
does is thanks his mom
you can't make that up if you put that
in a hollywood script
the producers would reject that they'd
say it's too on the nose that's too
ridiculous
but that's that's what's happening and
at no point
did jason sudaikis think there was any
conflict here
this is one of the really insidious
effects of political correctness
is it makes you hold conflicting views
simultaneously contradict reviews
simultaneously that's what george orwell
would call
doublethink he said that by the way
the totalitarian regime that he
describes in 1984 relies perhaps most
importantly on doublethink
that is what we are seeing here if you
enjoyed that video be sure to hit the
subscribe button so everyone waiting
through the wasteland of youtube
knows that we have got the absolute top
content
out there
[Music]
[Music]
you